und jetzt ziehen wir einfach mal bilanz
wie läuft es denn eigentlich bei der bom
flicht dem aufregerthema zum neuen jahr
es ist ja so alle hassen erlassen seit
dem ersten januar werden wir deutschen
bei jedem sesam brötchen gefragt ob wir
einen bon dazu brauchen
das kostet jedes mal bis zu zwei
sekunden lebenszeit die mir keiner
zurück gibt
tatsächlich ist die empörte bon
berichterstattung inzwischen ein eigenes
tv genre jeden tag über 300 kassenzettel
etwa 700 bis 1 kilometer lang rollen
zusammengeklebt etwa 3,5 kilometer eine
länge von 110 kilometern mit 18.000
kilometer papier zusätzlich
zusammengezählt eine 2,2 millionen
kilometer langen kassenbon pro jahr
damit ließe sich die erde rund 50 mal
umwickeln ja aber warum sollte man das
machen
also natürlich sind box aus giftigem
thermopapier im jahr 2020 nicht richtig
zeitgemäß und niemand mag bürokratie
allerdings hatten die einzelhändler seit
2016 zeit manipulationssichere kassen
einzuführen und experten schätzen den
schaden durch alltäglichen
abrechnungsbetrug auf mindestens 10
milliarden pro jahr ist konservativ
geschätzt klar
der frust der bäcker ist verständlich da
herrscht vor lauter bons quasi
alarmstufe brot den ganztag logisch
trotzdem kann ich nicht fassen dass zum
beispiel wirtschaftsminister altmaier
jetzt die bons pflicht attackiert die
seine eigene gruppe beschlossen hat das
thema ist so hoch emotional dass sogar
ein olaf scholz plötzlich aus sich
herausgeht sie haben richtig gehört olaf
scholz
wenn ich jetzt einkaufen gehe fragt mich
auch jeder ganz ausdrücklich herr scholz
möchten sie einen baum
und ich sage gerne ja da war überhaupt
nichts lustig aber egal
übrigens die hersteller von
elektronischen kassen begrüßen die bom
flicht ausdrücklich weil die nämlich von
ihren kunden regelmäßig bedrängt wurden
im sinne von hass eine software mit der
sich bescheißen kann ja was jetzt gar
nicht so oft bei bäckern passiert nach
meinen informationen aber zum beispiel
öfter in der gastronomie dass das ist
wohl so in deutschland in deutschland
sind immer noch pc kassen im einsatz die
laufen auf windows das heißt jedes baby
kann die manipulieren
kurz gesagt so nervig dieser brauch ist
er ist eine art hilferuf und wie so oft
im leben eine steilvorlage für afd
horrorszenarien aber ich stelle mir das
im jahr 2020 einmal so vor
neulich beim bäcker vor mir ein kunde im
gespräch die verkäuferin hier bonn bitte
der kunde brauche keinen die verkäufer
sie müssen aber einnehmen der kunden ein
ich will aber nicht riesiges handgemenge
ja klar
ja klar das haben wir doch alles schon
erlebt oder natürlich jeden morgen du
traust dich in deutschland nicht mehr
zum bäcker
wegen der ständigen handgemenge mir
reicht's jetzt jetzt wird das sogar
verfilmt
er wollte eigentlich nur einen kaffee
kaufen
und ihr
[Musik]
wo dann eine schnecke bitte
beim bäcker wirklich niemand
[Applaus]
erschließen
es ist ein theater in frankreich selbst
in italien und griechenland gibt es
längst eine bong schlecht haben wir
nicht ständig diese witze gemacht dass
es im griechischen kein wort für
quittung gibt hier sind wir selber
griechen manche branchen haben sich
übrigens noch gar nicht auf die neuen
regelungen eingestellt stichwort
prostitution ja ja ist jetzt kein witz
und herren das jetzt kein witz nein
wirklich wahre geschichte in darmstadt
hat ein mann nach einem bordellbesuch
sogar die polizei gerufen weil man ihm
dort keine quittung ausstellen wollte
zur erheiterung dieses steuerberater
es mag absolute einzelfälle geben wo
sowas vielleicht als betriebsausgabe
eingesetzt werden könnte wenn ich einen
beruflichen bezug dazu gibt also zum
einen spielt gibt es ja auch tester von
solchen etablissements
[Applaus]
viele zum lachen gebracht
und ich glaube der macht sonst niemand
so wir halten fest operation bonk licht
läuft der allgemeine kampf gegen
steuerhinterziehung in deutschland der
läuft allerdings eher schleppend also
höflich formuliert man schätzt
tatsächlich das uns aktuell dadurch also
durch steuerbetrug jedes jahr 125
milliarden euro durch die lappen gehen
125 ist ein drittel des bundeshaushalts
satz begrüßte jetzt ulrich von heesen
sprecher des verbands der besonders
wendigen steuerberater er verlesen
die zahl der betriebsprüfung ist in den
letzten zehn jahren in deutschland um
rund 30 prozent zurückgegangen was sagt
uns das ja das sagt uns was ich meinen
kunden auch immer sagen ihr müsst
dringend ist reich werden alles andere
ist quatsch
menschen mit jahreseinkünften über
500.000 euro werden vom finanzamt immer
seltener geprüft ist tatsache
weil man diese leistungsträger
bekanntlich scheue rehe nicht von der
lichtung jagen will
ja aber man muss doch für unser
gemeinwesen steuern zahlen natürlich
aber dafür haben wir ja die
mittelschicht
deswegen kann ich als windiger
steuerberater wirklich nur jeden
zuschauer raten seien sie auf keinen
fall teil der mittelschicht
wissen sie wahrscheinlich gar nicht
welche weil sie schlau sind und
selbstständig aber angestellten wird
wohl eine sogenannte lohnsteuer direkt
abgezogen
ja doch wirklich ja und dann zahlen die
auch nur irgendwas das nennt sich wohl
sozialabgaben
was soll das denn sein ja keine ahnung
deswegen mein rat an alle bloß nicht
mittelschicht seien entweder ganz arm
oder ganz reich mitte sein ist total
doof
darf ich mal in publikums handzeichen
bitten wer von ihnen ist irgendwo
angestellt und mittelschicht
sie sind total doof warum machen sie das
die menschen mit einem jahreseinkommen
bis zu 70.000 euro zahlen in deutschland
81 prozent der sozialabgaben
wie blöd kann man sein das ist ja das
ist ja voll ungerecht und gleichzeitig
lässt sich der staat sehenden auges mit
sowas wie comics geschäften beklauen ja
das lustig
diese woche kam raus die stadt hamburg
hat auf die rückzahlung von 47 millionen
euro verzichtet die sich die privatbank
warburg durch comex verschafft hat und
olaf scholz heute schwarze null damals
noch bürgermeister hat wohl den inhaber
der bank in seinem amtszimmer empfangen
obwohl da schon gegen die ermittelt
wurde
scholz letzten november mit dem witz der
woche comics war eine riesenschweinerei
[Applaus]
das war nicht nur frech und dreist das
war auch wie ich finde verachtenswert
und der typ macht heute an auf
kassenbons ja ja ja ja und dann sind bei
den deutschen finanzämtern also die auch
seiner verantwortung unterliegen auch
noch 6000 stellen unbesetzt er verlesen
was können die kleinen leute tun ja wie
die könnte auch bescheißen nur halt in
klein hier unglückliche wortwahl aber
völlig richtig leben über
steuerhinterziehung im großen stil
nennen man muss aufpassen es geht auch
im kleinen zigaretten schon mal auf dem
schwarzmarkt gekauft stein unterzogen
schwarze putzfrau gestellt
apropos mit der steuererklärung die sie
mir eingereicht haben bin ich auch nicht
so richtig glücklich so was stimmt ich
habe mich ja daran gewöhnt dass sie die
belegen alten pizzakarton stopfen aber
können sie sich vorher wenigstens die
pizza daraus
da ist noch ein stück du hier und was
ist das hier was ist das hier für ein
bewertungs belegt anlass der bewirtung
hunger einfach nur die wahrheit ullrich
[Applaus]
ja it-service beweise sprechen mit
jürgen wie kann ich ihnen weiterhelfen
haben sie mal versucht das gerät aus und
wieder einzuschalten hat nichts gebracht
verstehe
probieren sie doch mal den kanal der
heute show auf youtube zu abonnieren
genau und im zweifel wo ich auch mal den
gefällt mir -button klicken
genau ja ich bleibe in der leitung